let's talk about the world's biggest
economy because it affects just about
everyone
depending on what you read the us
economy is well on the way to recovery
after the crisis caused by coven 19. the
markets are buoyant
consumer confidence is decent or
it's stalling and leaving millions of
people behind
food insecurity homelessness and it's
not going to be repaired anytime soon
the whole world is trying to get back on
track but how long that will take
depends a lot on the americans what
happens in the united states
really does have an impact on the rest
of the world so who really created the
strong us economy before the pandemic
hit
is the recovery starting to slow and is
inequality
getting worse not better
[Music]
by some measures china these days is
considered the biggest economy in the
world
but when you look at the value of all of
its goods and services
the united states is still number one
[Music]
so what is the american economy it's
silicon valley
hollywood oil manufacturing finance
[Music]
it's pretty mixed the us is also the
most important export destination for a
fifth of all countries
that's because americans consume a lot
so much that they're the engine of the
us economy
the main driver is consumer spending it
accounts for roughly
two-thirds of u.s economic growth that's
literally consumers putting their hands
in their pockets going out and buying
things
and it all ripples throughout the fabric
of the global economy
so when our consumers are doing well in
this country that actually means that
businesses and employees and consumers
in other parts of the world
do better as well
[Music]
another reason the us economy matters to
all of us
is that the us dollar is the undisputed
king of currencies
most global transactions and trading in
things like oil and gold
are done in u.s dollars it wasn't always
that way
countries used to settle international
transactions in gold
but after world war ii countries needed
more flexibility to rebuild their
economies
and chose to peg their currencies to the
dollar
[Applause]
[Music]
that's because the u.s had the most gold
at the time
a strong dollar can be good or bad
depending on who you are
japan needs the dollar to be stronger
against the yen so american consumers
can afford more japanese products
but a country like turkey would rather a
weaker u.s currency
because banks and businesses there hold
a lot of debt in dollars
in other countries a strong dollar can
fuel inflation
in argentina that pushes up prices for
basic things like food
and in the u.s a strong greenback makes
imported goods cheaper
but it can harm u.s manufacturers by
making their goods more expensive abroad
overall though the dollar is largely
seen as a safe currency
during the pandemic it actually rose
it's the worst economic crisis in the
last 70 years
and there's one safe haven everyone is
banking on and it's not gold
it's the dollar lately the us dollar has
gone up and down
that has to do with all sorts of things
even a tweet from president trump can
help
or hurt the exchange rate but a lot
rides on how the u.s
economy performs so how is it doing
economies are measured using gdp which
is the total value of goods and services
produced in that country
over a period of time and you can see
that over the last 10 years the us
economy
has been growing last year gdp rose by
just over two percent
but it took a while to get there
[Music]
like the rest of the world the us
economy was devastated by the financial
crisis in 2008.
president george w bush started the
cleanup shoring up banks and rescuing
u.s companies
the federal reserve also played a
massive role
buying bonds and keeping interest rates
low
and all that continued under president
barack obama congress
spent hundreds of billions of dollars on
things like social security
and tax relief by 2009 the u.s had
started its longest economic expansion
on record then president donald trump
stepped in
from the instant i took office i moved
rapidly to revive the us economy
the economy did keep growing but the
four to six percent boost he promised
well that didn't happen he came into
office and inherited an economy had been
strongly growing
since 2010 so for six or seven years
growth was already baked in trump added
his own touch
he cut regulations to make doing
business easier
and got congress to pass tax cuts for
american workers and corporations
the promise there was to help businesses
reinvest money to create jobs
but it didn't always work that way a lot
of those companies use those tax savings
to buy back stocks and boost their value
instead
then there's trump's trade policy of
putting america first
he ripped up international trade deals
saying they were unfair
and hurt american manufacturing the
united states
has lost about 5 million manufacturing
jobs over the last 20 years
and about 91 000 factories we've seen
over the past few years um
tensions arise between us and between
some of our
trading partners and one of the things
that this current administration has
done
is put a focus on china i am the chosen
one
somebody had to do it so i'm taking on
china
and that led to a trade war the u.s
slapped penalties on hundreds of
billions of dollars worth of chinese
goods
china responded with their own china
also found ways around some of those
tariffs
they have succeeded in reducing imports
from china
but china has just rerouted those
imports through other countries the main
thing about trump's tenure was that the
american public started to feel a whole
lot better about the economy
and that had an important effect when
consumers feel confident about their
financial prospects
they're more likely to spend they're
more likely to go out and buy things on
credit
so the economy was in good shape and the
u.s jobs market was on fire
then covert 19 came along and pushed the
economy
off a cliff stocks crashing to their
worst losses in over 30 years
the u.s economy slid 5 in the first
quarter when it officially fell into
recession
then in the second quarter it nose dived
at a record annual rate of more than 30
we went from some of the lowest
unemployment rates in our nation's
history
to levels that have not been seen in
most of our lifetime certainly not
in in my lifetime the pandemic still
isn't over
but the focus now is on the economic
recovery in the third quarter of 2020
the economy bounced back a record 33
percent
the federal reserve helped by unleashing
a range of measures to keep credit
flowing to businesses and households
like cutting interest rates to make
borrowing cheaper congress also
allocated trillions of dollars in aid to
keep workers and businesses afloat
and jump start growth that's a lot of
money
that was a big help to u.s households
and a big boon to the economy because it
helped consumer spending
as you've seen some states reopen but
you've actually seen a
very sharp recovery the stock market
also came roaring back
one reason was that tech companies
benefited from the shift to people
working and
learning from home you know what else is
up house prices
mortgage rates are at a record low and
lockdowns have inspired many homeowners
to sell their digs for bigger ones in
the suburbs
so people who own shares or homes are
doing okay
but what about the rest while some
economists are saying
this is the most unequal recovery in
american history
those at the top those who can
telecommute who can
do their business by zoom are doing fine
in fact
many of those those individuals are
continuing to receive incomes and yet
they're spending less
so they're saving more and so their
wealth is going up
contrast that to somebody who cannot
work remotely
they're not doing well right now there's
a survey out that showed
that one in three renters did not pay
their rent on time
in the first week of september we also
see
very very sharp racial disparities as
well we also know that economic recovery
is starting to slow down
covet 19 is still spreading some of that
financial help we talked about has
expired
and republicans and democrats in
congress can't agree on the next aid
package
federal reserve chairman jerome powell
warned that without more
aid coming from the federal government
the u.s economic recovery is in jeopardy
the outlook for the economy is
extraordinarily uncertain there are
still roughly 11 million people still
out of work due to the pandemic
you don't want to see the recovery going
off the rails in the world's largest
economy
getting the us economy back to its
pre-pandemic strength
could take years and how long the virus
sticks around will make a difference
we know the world economy is
interconnected it's like an ecosystem
and on that basis the us needs to do
well
for all of us to turn the corner
[Music]
if you want to get a better
understanding of the stories in the news
you can find all of our episodes on
youtube just look for start here
you can also find us on al jazeera's
facebook page and
on our website aljazeera.com make sure
to subscribe wherever you're watching
and we'll see you next week
[Music]